You guys know Lixian, right?
Lixian: I wanted death!
He is the wonderful person, that has animated so many beloved animations on my channel,
Animated Mark: I hate everything you stand for
And he's been helping me out by editing my videos lately!
Breakfast, duh!
Well, he in his spare time decided to make me an entire game for my birthday
And that's amazing by itself, but also it came with this lovely note:
Hi Mark! I just wanted to say, thank you!
Thank you for everything. You've completely changed my life for the better!
You gave me so many opportunities, and I am so grateful and happy to be working alongside such an incredible person!
I wanted to show my appreciation for you and I feel like I don't do that enough.
I decided that, for your birthday, I would make you this small little game.
I had very little time to work on this (I started on June 3rd I believe)
so it is far from perfect, but I hope you can still enjoy it.
Happy (late) birthday and, once again,
Thank you for everything!
Sincerely, Luis (Lixian)
Disclaimer: I did not make any of the pretty assets.
So,
number one, I'm freaking honored that anyone would make a game for me
Uhh...
But also, he's not late. I am late. It is, it is July 31st, and he gave me this game like, uhh...
Only a couple days after my birthday as far as I believe.
So, I'm gonna play this
[Exaggerated inhale]
We're gonna do this, and it's gonna be cool.
No...
Wait a minute...
Wait a minute... [Chuckles]
Wait a minute.
Damien, huh? Okay, alright...
Oh no you did not. [chuckles]
Oh no, you did not!
Hang on a second here...
Looks familiar... [chuckles]
I get, I get the disclaimer for not making any of the pretty assets now
[tree falls slowly]
Alright...
Ok, cool...
I love it.
I mean, I love it just because it is Damien and I love that.
If you haven't seen Damien yet, there's probably gonna be spoilers,
## Subtitles guy here, I don't wanna get spoiled, so the rest of these subtitles have some issues ##
So go check it out on my channel.
## If you feel up to it, please help out by getting rid of the commentary and memes that don't belong in the subtitles! <3 ##
Oh what the hell is going on here? (chuckles)
What the hell is this? (chuckles)
(chuckles(bordering on laughing))
Wow! (chuckles)
Hell yeah! *reading* Pick up a log and place it on the stump
Oh hey!
Celine!
Celine! *wheezes*
CeLiNe!
Celine!
Hey, you're not looking at me! (I wonder why...)
(distorted) Why aren't you looking at me?
Celine?
CELINE?
Alright, fine then (F in chat)
Alright...
Bop
WAPOOF
Love it
Cool. Great.
Love it.
Alright. Okay. I see how this is
I see
Boom. Ok. And ASHAPUMP
I love how snappy everything is!
*gunshot sound*
God, man, all these games that are all loosey goosey, and this one's snappy
So fresh! A real talented game designer, this one!
Oh, I love the ambiance
Yeah, the one thing I love about indie horror-indie games, maybe it's a horror game, I don't know, is the ambiance!
Look at the- Actually look at this. I'm not even joking about this
This looks really good!
🎵Ah dah dee dee doo doo doo doo🎵
BOOM
oh
There I am
Celine: Don't slam the door Damien
Mark: DoN't tEll mE WhAt tO Do
Damien: I saw a flower today
Mark: I saw flowers
Damien: Shouldn't be long now before Spring
Mark: If you haven't seen Damien yet, go watch it
Celine: Or there's still a few more weeks of winter left, and that flower will die *Mark joins in* cold and alone
Damien: Or,
That
Either way, winter can't last forever Celine. With any luck,
We'll be able to get out of this cabin soon.
Celine: Luck doesn't keep the fire going! (*angry noises*)
Luck won't change the weather,
And luck definitely won't put food on the table (OwO *cocks shotgun*)
Damien: Well, I mean if you think about it
You probably do need some luck in finding something to eat in the middle of winter, out in the snow...
Ahem
Good luck!
Celine: Whatever. Try not to burn the cabin down while I'm out.
Damien: Aye aye, captain
Celine: Did you really see a flower?
Damien: Yes. A little pink one. Probably dead by now
Celine: Get some sleep. You look tired
Mark: No! No one's allowed to say i'm tired!
No one ever
Damien: Starting to sound like mom...
Mark: StArTiNg tO SoUnD LiKe mOm
Starting to sound like MOM
Okay. *reading* place 10 firewood in fireplace. You got it. Gonna get my axe. What do we got here?
Hmm, where'd this mirror come from? I don't remember that being there! Hmm
*reading* I'm not thirsty. You don't know that!
You don't know that! I'm not... I'm not tired. Yeah, definitely. Okay.
WHOOSH
Okay
SHUH BAH
(chuckle)
shoom
shu
hoof
doosh
haah
whaah
whaaah
What thrilling gameplay
Stunning graphics! I gotta say.
It really is, the pacing! Is... voondaba!
Maybe I'm tired well, maybe I am thirsty!
You don't- you know me!
I'm PRETTY thirsty
Can I leave? No? Ok alright
Go to bed!
*sniffle sniffle*
Lay my head to rest!
Ooh, hello! What the hell?
Ok... well this is new
Ooooooh
Ok...
ooh
*very loud ambiance*
Okay!
Oh, What? Did I die?
Wait, did I die somehow?
Oh, I was probably taking too much time! (chuckles)
I was just like... Ooh la dee dee everything looks so cool!
*ambiance* Uh oh
Oh. Uh oh
Oh! Ok alright! *reading* Get to the light!
I do understand, I'm gonna get to the light!
*sounds of fear*
Ah!
oh...
Oh I see
Now, ok that's pretty- that's pretty good
WOAH!
Hey there!
Hi!
What the hell
Okay?
Oh! Hi!
(chuckles)
Ohhhhhh
You, you silly, silly, silly, you silly, silly, silly, silly, silly, silly
Damien: Well you don't die easily, do you?
Mark: Oh, I'll tell you what dies easily. Me! In horror games
Warfstache: Why'd the music stop?
Mark: Hmm? Wha?
Damien: Hello?
Mark: Hello?
The Detective: You! Killed People!
So many people!
Damien: Who's there?
Mark: I can't believe how quickly he put this together
Like this is... really good
YAH. HIYAH. HIYAH. HIYAH. Take that Warfstache!
HIIIIYAH
Okay. *reading* Shift to sprint. I'm running back to the cabin!
*reading* I should investigate those voice first
Yeah I don't know about that!
Maybe, me am not want to do that!
Hello?
I love this, cause it's like an extended version
What? No way...
Hiyah! Ohhhhh
Wait, lemme check this way first
No, no, I'm gonna check this way
Hello?
Time for firewood. Hello? Here's Daim-y!
What's over here?
Oh! Hi. Oh!
Wha-wait a minute!
All right, let's move on. Cool.
All right, YUMP
Well good thing I collected the weird mannequin heads. Always like that
Where is this leading us?
There's a lot of environment here! There's a lot of really good stuff! How did he?
How'd he make this so quickly...
Do I got a leap over that? Do I gotta take a running yump? I can't yump...
So I guess... *gasp* do I get to push this? WOOAAAHHH
Really?
This is a treat that can't be beat
Thunk. Thunkus.
Man, these are some strong vines!
Thunkus
Look at those physics, It's a thing of beauty!
Anymore mannequin heads?
Hello?
Mann-u-quins?
anymore mann-u-quin heads
Hiyah! I love the, I love the speed of this axe!
It's quite satisfying
I gotta, I gotta admit! Even though things are obviously simplistic in this game, its, it's almost a meme for me to be
Appreciative of the finer details of it
I'm appreciating the finer details of it! Like it's it's not often that things are snappy like that
I feel like there's gonna be some heads here. It's a weird thing to say
Yeah, if there's like skulls in the next section, I I'm gonna have to replay through the game.
I just am becau-  whoooooooo
Oh no
Oh hi! Hey, how you doing? Oh what's up!
WOAH!
All right!
Cooooool
Good for you. Congratulations on whatever that was
Good show. You know what's fascinating about this is
it is like an extended cut because I actually wrote more stuff to be here and yet (chuckles)
And yet...
Here it is all coming out of Lixian's imagination. *reading* collect wood, you got it!
HEYYY CELINE!!!! DUNK DUNK
Hey- wha?
Wha? Woa? Wha? Wha? Wha?
Whaa?
Ok...
Guess I'll collect wood then!
Celine!
There's some weird stuff happening!
Look, is your text in the top corner of your head weird?
Mine's a little, acting funny
Okay, anyways Celine I don't know... I don't know what's going on, okay
HEYYYY
I'M COMING IN!
HA HA HA
Ok, woah
Ah the chimney. Alright I'm... coming in!
Hello...?
ok...
HADUNK
Mark: Don't slam door!
Celine: Don't slam the door Damien
Damien (mumbling): Uh huh, yeah, ok, yeah, sure
I saw a flower today. Shouldn't be long now before... Spring.
Celine and Damien: Or there's still a few more weeks of winter left and that flower will cold and alone...
Celine:  What are you muttering about?
Damien: I heard... a voice today
Mark: I also saw a ghost
Celine: What?
Mark: A demon
Damien: I heard a voice. As clear as I'm hearing you.
Celine: There's no one else in these woods, Damien
Damien: But it sounded far away
I should have followed the voice but it trailed off, and I had to get back with the firewood
But...
We have plenty of firewood...
Celine: Damien there is no one else in these woods! If there WERE... I'm sure I would have run into them by now
Damien (mumbling): I'm sure you would have run into them by now...
Celine: You NEED to sleep. Are you staying up while I'm out?
Damien: What? No! I'm fine, I'm not even tired
What about you? Are you tired? You're always awake by the time I get back...
Celine: I'm not a growing boy like you, little brother
Damien: Oh, please you're older by 10 minutes
Celine: Which is just long enough for me to be in charge
So shut up and go to bed.
Damien: That doesn't make you in charge. How does it make you the boss of me?
Just be careful. I don't know. Maybe I'm crazy but...
Whatever I heard out in those woods. It didn't sound too friendly
Just be careful.
Mark: You mean the thing that charged my face
Celine: I can take care of myself
Damien: Don't slam the door
Mark: DoN't sLaM ThE DoOr
Damien: You always need to be right
Sometimes I'm right
Sometimes I know things
Mark: Sometimes I know things. Oh, sometimes I don't know things... most times I don't
Ooh that's a lotta firewood
*sigh* Anyway, am I thirsty now? Am I thirsty?
I might be thirsty... I'm not thirsty?
Hello
You sure?
*knock on the door* oooh
oh hoh
OOOOOH
UH OHHHH
UHHH OHHHHHH
aWOAH!
UH OHhH
uh oh
*footsteps outside*
*knocks on the door*
ohhh
Okay... okay... hello? wha-
You know what's fascinating is like... this
This makes me realize I could have gone so much farther with the horror in Damien, which is what I wanted to do
but I had such a limited amount of...
Experience with the medium and a lot of things, but this is cool
*quicker knocks on the door*
Hi, yes. Hello. I'm here. Can I help you?
Someone's a Grouchy Gus.
Damien: How did I not notice this?
Mark: I don't wanna! No i'm good! I don't need to check the mirror!
The mirror's fine! What are you talking about? Looks good from where I'm standing!
All mirror esc, and uh full of reflections!
Yeah
*reading* press E to check mirror. I don't know if-
Damien: Why can't I see myself?
Mark: I don't know, maybe...
Distorted voice: You aren't quite feeling like yourself, are you?
Mark: Hello
This is cool
This is REALLY cool
Distorted voice: It's time to wake up, Damien
Mark: Ohhh, *whispers* awesome
Damien: What?
Mark: I love this, my favorite moment of the whole, whole god damn thing
Damien: This doesn't make sense!
Mark: That's my favorite moment of the whole... whole goddamn thing
Damien: Am I dreaming? (Mark: I love this.)
Celine: Damien...
Damien: Celine!
Is that you!?
Mark: I wonder, wait. Did he find the music? Did he find what music this was because...
He did, didn't he...
Okay actually, I've turned around so much I have no idea where forward is
Damien: Celine!
Mark: Celine? Oh wait. No, that's the point. Oh, that's so cool
Celine: Damien!
Damien: Celine! Where are you!
Mark: Celine?
Oh this is so cool!
Celine (and whispering voice): Damien hurry!
Mark: Am I going the right way? Am I going the wrong- is there?
Damien: Celine!
Mark: It's so cool. Oh it's so cool. Oh, he's done such a good job with this. Oh, it's so cool.
oh
Ooh. Oh that's not good
Uh. Uh. Ohh
Oh that's not good
Oh
Oh should I? Should I- I'm gonna fight you!
NYAHH
WHOOO
Okay, maybe not fight. Maybe fight not. Maybe not the fight. Maybe don't do the fighting thing
Fighting: Not the best idea. Okay. Here we go
DUNK DUNK
Okay. Okay. Keep moving, don't look back. Why do I always look back in horror games?
I-i just don't kn-whOOOOOO
Okay. Closer then I thought. Okay. All right, cool. I bet there's a pile of heads somewhere in here. I bet there is
I bet there is! Oh, I bet I missed it! Oh, I probably missed it.
Oh, I don't know what the pile of heads is for, or if it's for anything actually
You still back there? Oh you so slow. He's so slow, you loser
loser, big lose
big loser
Damien: I've never seen this lake before...
Mark: Okay, I guess I gotta keep going then
Heyyy... Woah! Woah!
Woah!
WOAAAH
What the HELL
Why are there- HEY!
Oh. GOD!
WHAT THE HELL
That's so cool, that's so well done
I mean I totally screwed it up, but man
I love that we get a good view of that monsters taint on the way up, but man
Yeah, I think I gotta like follow the path or something
Ok...
Ooh
Ooh, AHH, OKAY
I might be goofing something a little bit I think (when are you not mark)
Just maybe? Get with me for just a second cuz I'm quite dumb
Straight for it! No moving!
Ho-Hoh there we go, okay, made it
Oh god!
It's really well done. This is well done. I mean it's obviously like
Done quickly, but man, it's done well
uh oh
oh no
not this again
no, not this again
ohh nooo
uh ohhhhh
Oh hi!
Hey- Hey how you doin?
The Actor: Damien, you are a hard man to find
Ohhhhhh that's soooo
Doh, that's so good. That's just so
Goddamn good, that's so gosh-darn
It's so good I literally
Like
That's just I
I love it
Thank you
Thank you very much for making this I I
I'm just like, I'm so tickled that
I'm chuffed!
Damien was such a passion project and
If I could go back and take what I've learned now
Like I would enhance it in the way that Lixian has enhanced it, but now you know
You can get a little taste of some more horror to it. That's so cool
I don't know what this the heads were about if that was an Easter Egg or if that was just a one-off thing
man,
I loved it.
I really loved it.
I want to give
I want to give a thank you to Lixian right now
You gave me a nice thank-you at the beginning of this
So I'm going to give you a nice thank-you at the end of it
Well, I mean you can decide if it's nice or not once I'm done with it, but first and foremost
I have met a lot of talented hard-working people in my time on YouTube
Not one of them
Compares to the dedication the skill like the commitment and just the sheer speed at which you work
It's stunning. I have no idea how you do it
You have been helping me with
My channel since almost the very beginning the first animation that I ever saw
This is for people at home. The first animation that I ever saw someone make about my videos was Lixian's animation
It blew me away. I had no idea that could even happen
I didn't even know what like the format was but Lixian made it
I reached out to him and ever since then he has made
Landmark animations on my channel they are amazing
They are part of the reason why I'm able to be here today
Make no mistake. I would not be here
My channel would not be nearly as big I would not have nearly as much success without you Lixian
You are an integral part of this community
You're an integral part of this channel and I am so grateful that you are not only helping me
With editing videos and doing them better than I ever could
but also taking the time out of your day to make this just for my birthday and to kick up a project that I-
I was very passionate about and take it to like another level. That's stunning
That's so crazy. Like damn you for being so talented. I just you know, I am
I'm grateful
I'm really really truly grateful and I never want to take your talent for granted.
I never want to take your time for granted. I never want to take anything that you offer to me for granted because
You deserve all the praise in the world
for doing what you do
And if everyone at home watching doesn't know, Lixian also makes videos on his channel LixianTV
I I've been starting linking
his channel in every video that he edits for me, which is the majority of them now and
If you guys want to see who Lixian is, what kind of stuff he makes and just like follow him in his own capacity
Go in the description click on that link to go to LixianTV and check out his stuff and please subscribe to him
He's amazing
and Lixian
How dare you
Improve on something that I thought couldn't be improved on! How dare you!
how dare
you
But sincerely, thank you
I'm very
very fortunate to have you on my team and I
Cannot thank you enough
So, thank you and thank you everybody for watching at home and
Thank the world. Thank
Oxygen! oxygen is great. Everyone needs to thank oxygen. We wouldn't be here without oxygen
So thank you. If you want to see the original Damien, you can check it out in the in the description. I'll link it and
Yeah, just this is so cool this is so cool I can't express how cool this is
But thank you and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh Bye!
(Thanks for reading my subtitles, BYE)